après la mort de mon père, les zones de [ __ ]
vous m'avez interdit dans sa vie mon
héritage
êtes-vous dr.  P ceci autour du site
intéresse mon bureau je te rencontre à l'
extérieur tu es entré aujourd'hui oui
nous sommes des médecins conducteurs nous sommes là pour
aider les blessés
tu essaies de dormir un peu je ne suis pas fatigué
donc nous ne sommes pas fatigués tous les deux
[Musique]
il n'y a rien de sacré
tout est secret
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on a besoin de ton aide dans la saleté on
n'aide pas ce n'est pas toi tu ne sais même pas
[Musique]
J'ai réalisé que la vérité était vraiment
ma sœur
[Musique]
[Musique
]  Je te
reverrais Je regarderais le désert
Je dirai ton nom
et je verrai ton visage
[Musique]